this morning our series pushing the
limits follows one man's incredible
journey from prison to some of the
world's biggest athletic stages markel
taylor stunned the running role when he
qualified for the boston marathon in a
very unusual way you could say taylor
spoke with our lead national
correspondent david bagnow and his new
producer alyssa this is her first piece
of wall pay attention about overcoming
obstacles and finding the will to create
new starting lines in the game of life
if you were to say to markel taylor hey
man what is your secret to success
he just might say if you fall in life
just get up and keep running
at 49 years old he is gearing up for the
chicago marathon this fall
the streets of california is where he
trains
that's where i was raised right here
not bad for the views
beautiful
but for nearly 18 years taylor could
only dream of training in the scenic
city by the bay
from his window at san quentin state
prison when you got sentenced did you
think you were going away for life yes
yeah i didn't think i would never get
out in 2001 he physically assaulted his
pregnant girlfriend
when she went to the ground she said
i felt like
the baby stopped moving the instinct
came on again like what the hell did i
do why did i do this what the hell is
going on so they convicted you
for the death of your son yes
after you abused his mother yes
what was the sentence
they made it 15 years of life it was a
life-changing moment for a man who says
he was a victim of violence as a boy we
would get abused
if the dishes ain't washed
or if the house ain't clean or if it
ain't clinging to their specifications
then we will get whooped out of our
sleep
out of your sleep out of our sleep did
something about that say to you that hey
hitting people is how you handle things
yes that was their connection there
growing up
did anybody tell you they were proud of
you
only my teachers
ironically it took going to prison for
him to hear words like that again inside
taylor joined the 1 000 mile running
club it's a track team at the prison led
by volunteer coaches
his speed earned him a nickname markell
the gazelle they called him it's a story
that will be highlighted in a
documentary coming out soon how many
races did you run in prison every month
we had a race
how many did you win
i won every one of them except for one
what were the euphoric feelings that you
got running in prison i got an emotional
high an emotional high an emotional
ha-ha it was also because when i ran i
ran
to honor my son it was like that you
know what
you made a mistake
but keep running we have faith in you to
be a better person
nice markel
that faith stemmed from the kindness of
his coaches strong head up nice
like diana fitzpatrick great workout you
have a choice when you end up at a place
like san quentin and you can just
lay around and let the time go by and
wait for something to happen or you can
take control of your life and try to do
something with it and markel someone who
really chose to do something with his
life did it ever occur to you
that
you showing him that he mattered yeah is
maybe why you got the best out of him i
guess
i always believed in markelle okay
stride and
trusted him it makes me feel happy
so i
yeah
with that support
markel taylor did something that has
never been done at san quentin before
he ran a marathon that was so fast he
qualified for the 2019 boston marathon
and get this
a month before the marathon he was
released on parole after serving nearly
18 years
and they gave him special permission to
race i couldn't really enjoy boston
because i was still
being happy and appreciative
of just being free well this spring he
went back and ran boston again
off parole
and truly a free man what was the time
then
252 flat
and that is a time so speedy he placed
in the top five percent of all the
runners it's now your drug
exactly it's not my drug but it's a
positive good drug that don't hurt
people that's right it helps people
he's been given a new starting line at
life
he's now got his own one bedroom
apartment where he's starting to cook
again
he got promoted at the grocery store
where they took a chance on him his boss
told us he is a humble warrior have a
good dinner thank you
new opportunities for a new man
who's moving in the right direction
what do i see in your eyes
someone that stopped running that
don't need to run no more that could
stand up to
all my fears and anxieties i feel like
i signed the pledge of
being non-violent and i know that
not only do i owe it to myself and the
people who are victimized in my lifetime
i owe it to all those who are counting
on me and people who are looking for me
to be a positive influence in their life
all right
what do i look like
what is my tombstone gonna say later
when i pass what would you like for it
to say
that he failed but he got up
and he changed the life of a lot of
human beings for the better
that's why i keep doing it sometimes i
have to do stuff like this to continue
to validate myself this type of stuff
helps keep you accountable doesn't it
exactly that's what it is the
accountability yeah
yeah
that's what it is
[Music]
oh david you did it again
proud of that dude you fell but he got
up
you know my big takeaway too were
you know not just diana fitzpatrick the
coach who is a volunteer yeah but also
his teachers
we don't talk enough about that how a
teacher or coach or somebody in your
life not your parents can set you on a
track
i talked to a change
talked to his boss last night she said
he came into the grocery store and
applied to work at the deli and he
didn't seem like a right fit so we
didn't hire him and she said then i got
a call from my family doctor
and he said i want you to do me a favor
and take a chance on this guy because i
believe in him and it reminds me as
human beings i feel like we have an
obligation to give people a second
chance he did the time he did the time
the time
and he's going to make the rest of his
life not only better for himself but for
other people i'm sure he's haunted by
the death of his son by his own hand but
i do think it's important that we are
products of our environment not to
excuse at all what he's done but we are
products of our environment it's good to
see that he wants to do something good
with that and he's looking for somebody
to give him his next chance and we have
to remember to give ourselves a second
chance amen well done david we'll be
right back